dizem que o brasil é um paraíso tropical
que aqui não tem desastres naturais
a gente não tem isso não me e não têm
terremotos muito intenso não tem vulcões
tem até música pra isso você deve
conhecer aquela que diz que moro num
país tropical abençoado por deus e
bonito por natureza mas que beleza né em
fevereiro tem o que isso enchente toda
fevereiro tem xente e eu sei disso
porque eu sou paulistano ea 36 anos é o
mesmo padrão
chega o verão o céu escurece vem chuva
forte a rua enche os programas de tv
colocam seus apresentadores
sensacionalistas para gritar e os
políticos colocam a culpa em são pedro
ea população por outro lado está
sofrendo os efeitos disso seus carros
casas bens móveis e imóveis álbuns de
família falando em família a minha é
daqui mesmo
a gente já morou em cada canto da cidade
e eu lembro um pouco da minha infância
que eu cruzava a cidade entre onde
morava e estudava morava na zona norte
estava na zona sul
é eu sempre fui uma criança além de
muito preguiçosa para acordar de manhã
eu era super tímida e os bons e tímido é
que você fala pouco mas você escuta e
observa muito e eu adorava observar o
que aconteceu durante esse trajeto
eu lembro de algumas coisas que se
repetiam netinha sempre tive um sonho
que vem disse flávia que me salvou
algumas vezes tinham os bichos e
grafites que de alguma forma eles me
provocavam e convidavam ali a
estabelecer uma conversa sobre a cidade
e tinha também não sei quem vencer tem
alguém que são paulo que lembra uma
música que me irritava que tocava às 7
horas da manhã
era mais ou menos assim vambora vambora
tá na hora vambora vambora vambora
e isso se repetir e aí entra um cara
falou o site da manhã repita sete da
manhã eu falava meu deus é 7 da manhã
que estão cantando né
só que mais me irritava nessa música era
o tal do van gogh hora embora pra onde
diferente das crianças eu nunca soube o
que eu queria fazer quando crescesse e
na minha família também a referência que
eu tinha era super tradicional é uma
família de médicos engenheiros advogados
e o padrão de vida àquele nasce e se
forma nas escolas farão a faculdade
fazer um mba executivo cria uma carreira
tem uma família se aposente morra aquilo
de alguma forma me encaixava dentro de
mim nem olhava para aquele padrão tão
linear tão previsível não era exatamente
o que eu queria o que eu imaginava mas
também não teve muita escolha
comecei esse caminho bastante
convencional
fui pra escola foi um bom aluno nunca
peguei dependência ou repetirá uma série
e aí vai fazer dois do joguinho que era
da faculdade vão escolher o que fazer da
vida com 17 anos e 6 anos e eu tomei a
decisão de escolher engenharia
então a decisão de progéria nesta casa
que cá estamos na mauá
a engenharia me trouxe muitos
aprendizados entre eles uma palavra
especial que a tal da resiliência é
resiliente à segunda fase que é a
capacidade que o corpo tem de ser
deformado e logicamente retornar à sua
forma original e eu posso dizer que eu
fui bem de formado aqui reitora mas o
senhor não estava aqui ainda então
começou logo na primeira prova né física
1 sair da prova
achei 10 tirei dois já foi aquele
primeiro bem-vinda engenharia foi aquele
primeiro susto e falaram tudo bem vamos
lá terminou o ano que aconteceu três
dependências repetir e ali foi o
primeiro momento de grande decepção da
minha vida é o que mais pros meus pais
do que pra mim investir nele todo o
tempo e esforço de investir em uma
faculdade privada e
e não necessariamente conseguir
retribuir aquilo como eles esperavam
foi aquele momento de que eu faço ficou
fazer publicidade agora num engenharia
que eu preciso fazer vou fazer outra
coisa mas não eu preferia insistir
lembrei dessa palavra eu falei vamos lá
eu acho que tem tem mais coisa para
explorar aqui no segundo ano aqui e
resolvi fazer tudo me envolvi com
atlético foi do time de vôlei da mauá
nunca perdemos pra frente
participei de empresa júnior também esse
diretor da empresa júnior ii e no um
segundo eu consegui um estágio numa
grande multinacional que não sei se foi
a melhor escolha que eu fiz na época
mais foi o que aconteceu no final
daquele ano fiquei esgotado 100%
esgotado
eu odeio falar essa palavra mas aquele
tal do pênalti só falando desse jeito
parece que foi tudo ruim aqui né a fruta
foi péssimo e super grato a essa escola
e eu queria aproveitar esse palco para
compartilhar com vocês que foi aqui no
bloco de que eu conheci ela foi nessa
escola que a gente viu pela primeira vez
e eu conheci a minha primeira linha
street foi duro amigos e amigas foi
realmente difícil formar em engenharia
mas tudo certo e em 2005 estava nesse
estágio tava saindo é um dia de trabalho
e chuvoso
choveu o dia inteiro e tinha acabado
horário de estágio
eu tava me deslocando peguei meu carro
sair virei a esquina e eu virei me para
o trânsito para o trânsito e de repente
percebe uma movimentação esquisita
pessoas correndo não estava entendendo
direito aconteceu de repente quando
olhei pro lado tem água subindo e em
questão de cinco minutos ali a água
estava entrando no meu carro e eu não
estava entendendo mais nada tinha gente
correndo subindo em calçada voltando pra
postos para tentar fugir daquilo ali eu
não tive reação nenhuma a não ser ficar
ali no meio goiano e popular daquele
lugar e eu ficava pensando uma coisa que
falei caramba nunca ninguém me avisou
podia ficar um pouquinho mais aqui no
estágio hoje podia esperar esse negócio
passar
ninguém me avisou mas tudo bem foi um
outro evento foi super importante na
minha vida para ajudar a começar a
questionar algumas escolhas é porque que
aquilo aconteceu e que tipo de
privilégio que eu tinha aqui eu comecei
a entender o que era privilégio porque
pra mim não aconteceu muita coisa a
partir disso carro tinha seguro seguro
cobriu todos os danos que foram feitos
mas eu comecei a reconhecer que aquilo
não era uma coisa comum em pessoas que
passam por eventos desse tipo que não
têm esse mesmo privilégio
uma dessas pessoas é a rose que é uma
amiga nossa casa no jardim pantanal na
zona leste de são paulo é uma região de
várzea do rio tietê que todos os anos
acontece a mesma coisa
essa foi uma foto da casa dela do ano
passado e mais uma vez também não
avisaram a rose que esse evento e
acontecer muitas vezes ela família dela
é as pessoas ali que moram não consegue
nem se preparar não dorme muitas vezes à
noite porque isso pode chegar e levar
muitos dos seus bens e principalmente
parte da sua história
a má notícia é que isso não é só um caso
da rose não é só um caso do jardim
pantanal
hoje no brasil são mais de 30 milhões de
pessoas que são impactadas por esses
eventos o país já perde mais de 10
bilhões todos os anos
só no primeiro mês de 2007 foram mais de
50 bilhões perdidos por desastres
naturais
a gente olha para o mundo são 500
milhões de pessoas que se perdem mais de
300 400 bilhões todos os anos e tem um
estudo que diz do banco mundial que
disse que por conta das mudanças
climáticas eo aumento da freqüência
desses eventos extremos mais de 100
bilhões de pessoas vão ser levadas a
faixa de extrema pobreza se a gente não
fizer nada com o sistema legal legal não
claro que não
mas voltando pra minha história eu
seguir a vida né foi processado entre
outra empresa que trabalha na
consultoria até que em 2011 caiu a ficha
caiu a ficha de pra que eu estou usando
todo o conteúdo que tive oportunidade de
acessar toda a educação de ponta que eu
tive acesso será que estou ajudando a
rose que está ajudando essa galera eu
estou investindo meu tempo dedicando seu
tempo pra aumentar esse
buraco social que a gente foi inserido e
eu resolvi tomar uma decisão de romper
com esse ciclo e pros meus pais foi uma
tremenda dor de barriga nessa época mas
pra mim foi muito realizador
eu comecei a trabalhar com o tema quer
um tema novo no brasil e sim em 2010
2011 quer os negócios de impacto social
que são empresas que geram lucro mas
atividade principal delas é melhorar a
qualidade de vida geral mais acesso para
a população de baixa renda
eu fiquei maluco quando tiver acesso ao
sistema eu falei caramba dá pra ganhar
dinheiro mudar o mundo ao mesmo tempo
era isso que eu queria era isso que me
motiva e me joguei nisso aí já comecei
logo com uma empresa de educação para
não vamos lá vamos lá e sabe aquelas
pelas listas que saem revistas sites e
os 10 erros que o empreendedor não pode
cometer
eu consegui achar que em todos em seis
meses cumprir com sucesso
falhar muito uma muito rápido o que foi
excelente porque eu aprendi coisas muito
rápidas do que é empreender de
residência
depois disso entrei numa outra empresa
entrei numa ong entrei várias outras
iniciativas mas ainda não tinha
encaixado até que em 2015
me liga um colega na época de
consultoria a nota voltando para são
paulo eu o o hotel a gente está pensando
em criar alguma coisa né com mais
propósito também já está cansado do
mundo corporativo e executivo
a gente se juntou em 2015 para criar
algum negócio que juntasse propósito e
tecnologia que a tecnologia é a base
para a gente conseguir escalar a gente
conseguir de fato gerar mais impacto e
levar isso para o mundo inteiro
só que na época a gente não tinha ideia
nenhuma 00 00 de idéias que a gente vai
fazer o que você faz quando não sabe o
que fazer vai fazer curso vai conhecer
gente ea gente se aplicou para um curso
de futurismo na época e nesse curso a
gente aprendeu muito sobre
nanotecnologia
a robótica internet das coisas
inteligência artificial inteligência
artificial interessantes negócio
isso tem tudo a ver com padrões e aí
começou a voltar um monte de coisa na
minha cabeça da minha infância fora e
será que aquele negócio que se repete
todo ano a gente consegue identificar um
padrão certo a gente consegue entender
que tipo de chuva
gera um evento de enchente e se a gente
consegue identificar isso é que eu
consiga avisar antes as pessoas para se
proteger já que a enchente a gente não
vai conseguir exatamente evitar
e foi aí que surgiu a idéia da gente
criar por john
aprovei um agente fundou em 2016
com esse propósito de salvar vidas e
reduzir as perdas foram geradas por
esses eventos em toda a economia
brasileira ea gente começou também com o
tesão tipo não vamos rodar redes neurais
vamos atrás de dados vão ver o que tem e
foi um choque já logo de cara
a gente descobriu que ainda faltam
muitos dados meteorológicos no brasil e
esse é um problema que afeta vários
setores e se a gente queria cumprir
aquele propósito que a gente tinha
definido a gente não podia depender do
que existir que quisesse daquele alerta
antecipado para pessoas até se proteger
a gente precisaria de alguns passos
atrás e criar nossa própria rede de
dados
e foi aí que a gente resolveu investir
nesse negócio e essa é esse é o primeiro
protótipo da nossa fantástica estação
meteorológica
com um investimento de aproximadamente
40 reais e uma embalagem de um lustre da
casa do pedrão a gente conseguiu provar
que dá para transformar chuva em dados e
com esse protótipo a gente começou a
chamar a atenção de marcas de marcas
como o red bull facebook que nos
convidaram para participar de programas
de residência que eles tinham e daí
começou a nascer essa idéia
dois anos depois a gente já bateu
bastante cabeça aquela caixinha já
passou por umas dez versões e chegou
numa versão hoje
industrial escalável muito mais
acessível inteligente já conectado em
rede de internet das coisas
com essa solução a gente já hoje tem
mais de 200 pontos monitorados em nove
estados brasileiros
a gente já tem de setores como
agricultura cidades transportes à
energia e todo mundo que de alguma forma
impactado pelo tempo e esse ano a gente
a gente vai poder tirar de fato o
projeto que sempre sonhou
o agente contou com a ajuda dos nossos
amigos e nossa comunidade para fazer um
financiamento coletivo para criar um
projeto para a comunidade de são paulo
ea gente conseguiu financiar esse
projeto
então esse verão já vão ter várias
comunidades aqui de são paulo sendo
ampliadas ea gente vai poder rodar a
ferramenta que a gente sempre quis que a
gente criou um assistente virtual um
chat botes para as pessoas adicionarem
como amigas tanto no facebook messenger
como notas ap ea gente carinhosamente
batizou de são pedro porque agora as
pessoas vão poder conversar direto com
quem conhece do negócio
esses a xingar alguém agora sim tem um
canal oficial de comunicação com 1 com o
santo e acho que o clube pra gente é
hoje o maior exercício de resiliência é
todos os dias tem alguém que fala fazer
raro no brasil ainda não há seis são
muito pequenos pra promover essa
transformação e eu me emociono porque
essa notícia veio no meio do ano passado
e à onu convidou a gente como a primeira
startup brasileira ea primeira primeira
etapa do mundo e primeira empresa
brasileira a fazer parte da plataforma
global de cidades inteligentes da onu em
notas mártires e 2
em dois anos conquistar esse tipo de
reconhecimento é muito muito
engrandecedor pra gente
só que a gente não pode parar por aí
porque realmente a gente precisa de mais
gente atuando no sistema que é um tema
global o impacto tão grande e tem uma
galera fazendo isso eu trouxe quatro
exemplos de gente que usam tecnologias
tanto processo da água como para a falta
dela é para o processo para chuvas e
enchentes a gente tem duas empresas de
grande animação e hd rã gigante
desculpas gigantes de tecnologia mas
está se usando torres de celular outro
usando antenas de de tv a cabo para
conseguir medir chuva e gerências
alertas e outras duas empresas
brasileiras aqui que trabalhou na seca
as meninas do sd w farol que criar um
mecanismo de levar água potável para o
semiárido brasileiro e um projeto novo
que ela como rede do rio de janeiro que
avisa as comunidades quando tem água
disponível que pra gente às vezes é uma
coisa tão comum mas eles precisam se
proteger também se tocar ali pra poder
garantir que vai ter água em casa a
gente tudo isso aqui é pra deixar esse
convite pra vocês
a gente precisa de mais gente com a
gente a gente é de muita gente para
transformar tanto a população como as
cidades e mais resilientes esses eventos
vão acontecer eles vão chegar uma
recorrência é maior nesses eventos
extremos chuvas fortes tempestades secas
ea gente precisa de mais gente a gente
por isso esse um cara que tirou nota 2
em física 1 está conseguindo fazer
alguma coisa nesse sentido se a gente
organizado direitinho todo mundo aqui
com essa galera que também está fazendo
a gente consegue fazer de fato
transformações gigantescas por lá fora
eu e toda essa galera aqui a gente não
pode ser mais o papo de cafezinho um
papo de elevador ele pode salvar vidas
obrigada
[Aplausos]